es la primera visita desde que estalló
la guerra civil siria hace 10 años este
sábado una delegación de ministros
libaneses llegó a damasco con una
solicitud de urgencia la necesidad de
transportar combustible y electricidad a
través del territorio vecino las
autoridades sirias aceptaron el pedido
de beirut
la parte libanesa solicitó la
posibilidad de ayuda para hacer pasar el
gas egipcio y la electricidad jordana a
través del territorio sirio
la parte siria acogió con satisfacción
nuestra petición y afirmó la disposición
de siria de cumplirla
las dos partes acordaron hacer un
seguimiento de los aspectos técnicos a
través de un equipo técnico conjunto
el
líbano sufre una fuerte crisis de
déficit energético desde hace meses que
se suma a la inestabilidad política y al
colapso económico calificado por el
banco mundial como una de las peores
crisis financieras del mundo en tiempos
modernos una situación que ha generado
protestas entre los ciudadanos que ven
como el relacionamiento de combustible y
los cortes de electricidad que pueden
durar hasta más de 20 horas afectan a
sus negocios
y
mi coche lleva dos días aparcado en la
cola de la gasolinera pero todavía no
tengo gasolina hay algo más degradante
que esto
las condiciones de vida son difíciles
debido al corte de electricidad a veces
nos vemos obligados a encender la luz de
un teléfono para poder seguir trabajando
para los clientes no hay electricidad ni
gasolina ni gas
varios políticos libaneses atacan la
falta de combustible en su país al
contrabando hacia siria que también
sufre un déficit energético debido a las
sanciones económicas impuestas por la
casa blanca sobre el régimen sirio algo
que podría complicar el reciente plan
sirio libanés y generar tensiones con
washington